Since the beginning of July, the temperature in mainland China has been high, and the
atmospheric pressure pattern that makes it easy for warm air to enter has continued,
so the temperature is higher than normal throughout the country
.
It looks like it's going to continue
The temperature tends to rise
more inland.
One of the victims
was taken to the hospital, but was in a state of cardiopulmonary arrest. Naoto Tachibana, a resident of
Shibuya Ward, Tokyo, was confirmed dead at the scene
.  20 on the road side of the site land
Bono Hachihana's rain living in Shibuya Ward, Tokyo
Hinata Tachibana 26 years old The
Metropolitan Police Department is increasing vigilance
Hachihana
is nice
[music]
Mm Tachibana, the only girlfriend I dated in junior high school
Hinata seems to have died I'm a
fan ah ah
ah ah yes ah ah ah ah ah ah yes ah ah yes
the sound of the day is loud I
'm sorry ah
young people these days um
dark how many times do you make them say the same thing
hey
Hanagaki Takemichi-kun dvj
I've said it many times, right?
You
[music]
Ah,
if I hadn't thought it would turn out like this, my life would end up like this
I live in a run-down apartment with thin walls The younger store manager at my part-time job does
n't use the car
I'm sorry for being looked down upon by those kids,
she's my life
Alone, even when I was in junior high school, it's still the ultimate,
where did I go wrong?
Hey, why are you? What are you
doing?  She was number two in the group,
and the
only time I had a
girlfriend.  To my
road to the target road
Eh, what are you doing in the world?
Well, I made it like a nageshi consumer mouth, and it
's not over, but I'm nervous about the pass, and I'm nervous.
I'm a
junior high school student.
Now it's true
[music]
I was there a year ago today
---- What are you doing on the dog road?  I'm really
glad that my
cousin from Target Road is the head of Shibuya Yamanaka If the
3rd year comes on a business trip, well, it would
be nice if I
could say Saru-kun's name.
Wait
, what's good when Yuu-kun comes in? I
can't grasp the situation at all,
but what is it
?  In Shibuya Mie like that, we
're at war for 12
years.From now on, we're going to get into that middle school and have a fight.
I
don't
care about pretending to be terribly free I want to see you again, so I guess I'll care about the hair on the back of my head Waveform road ekk I wonder if it
's our cut captain
The story unfolds quickly, and
this certainly happened
I went to talk to my cousin Masaru in order to get into junior high school in
Shibuya.
It's burning, isn't it?
Keep calm, so this is it.
It's
a
group boycott
Maybe these people ate it and
I got scared
Ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh  Choi
Koja teaboy Okay Shiga Uh-huh-ha-oh City Nenen Key Mad's guy-
these guys-
3 years
[music]
Cloth, it's a
school trip It's
13 and the biker gang cut
the real stuff
Free
] For the
time being, one by one they hit me in the chin
I guess that's why we
're sticking to the 3-year version We're
talking to each other well I
'm afraid
dero hi with
her mousse Even if you don't raise your voice, they can hear you
No, buy it for everyone, but right now
Um, this is it!
The fist of the upper level is 100 yen per shot.
It was a pity
I moved I was trying
to show off
to me I wanted to remember what would happen after this I was scared and had no
recourse We have this
[music]
Ah ah ah
Ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah oh oh oh oh oh
oh yeah Let's have some
fun Don't talk about bad things From
today
onwards,
we
'll be the
next soldiers in Tokyo
Hell days of being
abused All of these guys
That's why I
ran away from my hometown as soon as I graduated from junior high school I
'm sorry I started living alone and starting a part-
time
job  It
was a life where I kept apologizing for mistakes
Day
Yes
[Music]
It's okay I
'm the worst Soma at the end of my life
Okay God I don't
mind prosecuting my tax system Taro
Manner times broadcast is Tokyo man
Next time
that's right Tachibana died because of the heights who were younger
than
me
.
I can't eat it because my mouth is cut
open.
]
Ohana's period Yes
I remember this voice I have a
good
nose I'm current again I can't keep arguing We just got into
fights over trivial things last week It
's okay It looks
really painful
I'm going to be a potted flower [music] It's sunny [music] Why are you wearing it? I
'm not sorry.
Eh,
tell me properly I want to know anything about you
No, I'm cheering you on somewhere else
Ako
rubber
Yes,
I was always getting
scolded I was small and strong-
willed Uh, I'll be sour at school tomorrow
Damn,
that's not all I'm talking about
Don't lie
, try flying, don't you have a roller
yet
?
Ah,
Usu station,
disqualified, messy mess, yay,
ah,right now
, I'm picking the strongest, Chiero
Cross,
ah, rock,
it's dangerous if you do it in a place like
that
,
5 people,
thank you very much
I
'm from the same hometown Get
ready to be beaten
But
don't flinch No, a memo
is fine.
I
'm Naoto Tachibana from Chiba.
Is that
Naoto Tachibana
That's right
12 years later this guy will die I
'm Takemichi Hanagaki It's okay to
call me Takemichi I won't call you but Do you like my
sister?
I love your sister, I love you, I love you, I
love you so much that you can't help
but remember that.
But it's just a story
Today in 2017, I fell from the station platform onto the tracks
When I realized I thought I was dead, I was a junior high school student
12 years ago
What can I
say?  Maybe I'm just gay I'm
sure
God made me one last time with Tachibana
12 years later on July 1st
Your sister will
die
At that time
you will die with me
July 2017  One day
, remember this day,
Naoto, and then protect my sister
I can't believe it, can't you believe it?
[Music] I got
it
[Music]
[Applause]
I realized
this is the medical office at the station
You fell from the platform onto the tracks
2017  July 4,
2017 Was it a dream
?  It's been a long time I
'm Naoto Tachibana On
that day you supported my destiny
That day You
died You time leaped
And while I was alive I
saved the painful
Takeuchi-kun Takeuchi-kun is Time  Leaping
changed the present
I swear
12 years ago
you said to me
Remember this day
Naoto And I'll protect my sister
I studied hard
and became a police officer
In order to protect the sound
,
I made everything.
Help Data This is
Tachibana school
Muragu Let's get banned today as a regular
ana Stand side by side with your shoulders and crouch down
ani
I spend all my time with you I'm
worried about my wounds
[music]
ni da gyaaaaah that was goo me
re alone ah ah